wednesday edition of pft ot the digital
program where we discuss things we
didn't get to during pft live chris sims
mike florio one of the things we talked
about on tuesdays pft live the mike
gundy controversy photograph wearing the
one american news t-shirt shuba hubbard
2000-yard rusher last year for oklahoma
state reacting strongly the two men
posting a video where one apologized one
didn't although the wrong one apologized
chuba hubbard apologized for making an
issue out of it on twitter he had every
right to do it he was he was in his
rights to do it and it was the right
thing to do gandhi didn't apologize
chris we talked about that a lot
now
apparently we're not the only ones who
had a problem with the initial video
so there was a second video with just
gundy that emerged late yesterday
afternoon on social media we're going to
play it for you then we're going to give
you our thoughts on
what it means why he did it and where it
goes from here here's mike gundy with
his second attempt at putting the
toothpaste back in the tube i had a
great meeting with our team today
our players expressed their feelings as
individuals and as team members
they helped me see through their eyes
how the t-shirt affected their hearts
once i learned how that network felt
about black lives matter
i was disgusted and knew it was
completely unacceptable to me
i want to apologize to all members of
our team
former players and their families
for the pain and discomfort that has
been caused over the last two days
black lives matter to me
our players matter to me
these meetings with our team have been
eye-opening and will result in positive
changes for oklahoma state football
i sincerely hope
the oklahoma state family near and far
will accept my humble apology as we move
forward
once you get past the fact that it's
impossible to reconcile dark brown hair
with a gray beard
you look at the demeanor you look at the
delivery this is a guy who does not want
to be here this is a guy who is reading
the words that are in front of him
because someone told him a teleprompter
this is what you need to do look like
you're facing a revolt good luck
recruiting if you don't find a way to
fix this he he did not want to be there
i mean you can just tell the way i he
just did that is not a heartfelt apology
that is
son of a
i can't believe i have to do this why do
i have to do this they're making me do
this i'm reading these words it's like
he's trying to get through a prostate
exam it's look i don't buy it and i
think a lot of people agree that it's
not a true apology it's not a heartfelt
apology this is an effort to avoid a
damn break that would wash him right out
of stillwater well i agree with you the
body language didn't necessarily exude
like
you know i i don't know i'm really i'm
really passionate about me being wrong
and i'm sorry and i messed up yeah it
was almost like okay i'll read this
teleprompter and i'm a little bit of a
beaten down puppy and that puppy eye
look here and i'll i'll you know do it
that way
um listen it's it's so bad hey
i didn't the message i got from the eyes
was not puppy dog it was bleep you that
was the message i got through the eyes
yeah maybe it is uh either way you know
i'll return the look then bleep you
because it's just stupid all right that
you wore that shirt and you're that
clueless of to what you're wearing which
i don't buy get the hell out of here
with that you know then you're then one
you're not that smart or two you're
insensitive it's one of the two but did
not know some of those things that are
related to oan and the crazy conspiracy
things and all that and you know you're
on record for telling everybody it's the
news and they don't there's no right no
left it's just the truth just the news
what what news are you talking about and
especially to black lives matter it's
disgusting and disrespectful and stupid
and it's one of the biggest reasons
we're in this issue in our country
anyways mr gundy okay so i would tell
you all my i know i just want to say
don't go to school there that's what i
want to say don't go to sleep
thank you please chris tell us how you
really feel here's what gundy said in
early april
i was flipping through the stations i
found one and this is early april i
don't even know if anybody knows about
this it's called oan it's one american
news and it was so refreshing they just
report the news there's no commentary
there's no opinions there's no left
there's no right they just reported the
news and i've been watching them the
last week because they've given us the
news and given us more information in my
opinion some of the positives are coming
out so that was refreshing now that was
said in conjunction with the pandemic
back when he said some stupid things he
had to apologize for about bringing the
kids back and and concerned about the
money generated by the program even
though the kids don't get any of it and
yeah mike you were wrong on that issue
gundy i mean you were wrong on that
issue because you were taking
information from a not a credible news
source that's why so you were wrong
there again because they were giving you
the right news no they were giving you a
bunch of bull crap that was misleading
one of the issues in our country sorry i
had to say it i can't i couldn't you
know you're fine and here's the thing
here's the thing i've seen so many
people
uh uh whether they're just misinformed
whether they're blowing a dog whistle
for the benefit of those who want to
side with gundy on this
this isn't about wearing a t-shirt of
a cable news network and as we said
yesterday who in the hell wears any
cable news network t-shirt anyway i've
heard well if you had an msnbc t-shirt
it would have been fine who the hell
wears that who does that who where i've
never seen t-shirts of cable news
networks but beyond that
this isn't about the political beliefs
of a coach this isn't about what tv
shows he watches this is about
a cable news network that as gundy said
himself he's disgusted by their
treatment and their attitude toward
black lives matter one of the hosts
called it a criminal organization
it is when you are a guy who is making
five million dollars a year
from a football program that can afford
to pay you five million dollars a year
because it doesn't pay its players and
the majority of the players are black
and you are supporting a network that
espouses views that are
contrary to the interests of black
americans that's where it becomes
something more than political preference
or which tv shows you choose to watch or
things that otherwise don't matter when
it comes to who your coaches and what
your coach does yes at the end of the
day you just wanted to coach the team
but when you look at the makeup of the
team
if he is
supporting
a news outlet
that espouses views that are hostile to
the interests of the guys who make up
the team that's when it becomes a
problem that's when the players have the
right to stand up and say
hey
you you're making five million dollars a
year off of us we don't get any of it
and and and you're not sensitive to the
issues that we are dealing with every
day as young black men in america that's
the point here and it's so easy for the
charlatans out there who know how to
blow that dog whistle and know how to
confuse people and know how to give the
people who are closet racist or flat-out
racist the red meat that they can gnaw
on all day long oh
who cares about a t-shirt it's just a
t-shirt no it's more than just a t-shirt
it's the message that the t-shirt sends
and i i chuba hubbard did the right
thing he should not have apologized and
gundy's apology sorry mike i don't buy
it and i think a lot of people agree
with us that it's not a real apology
it's not a heartfelt apology and he's
gonna have a hell of a time getting the
best of the best black athletes to go to
oklahoma state given the oan t-shirt
controversy no doubt why the hell would
you want to send your kid there or what
if you're an african-american kid why
the hell would you want to go play for
him i don't you know i'm sorry that's
just the that's the the facts that
matter how i see it and i think that's
what's gonna happen and unfortunately
really too with these great leadership
positions that do all this stuff and
everything like that you know
nobody's gonna be like hold them truly
accountable for this it's probably going
to take the results on the field
to be bad for him to
suffer some consequences but i think he
started that himself now i do you know
mike you bring up a lot of great points
and yeah hey it's your head coach and
you know do you want to play for this
guy of course the team is mainly
african-american how many times have we
heard like players talk about man i just
i wanted to i wanted to please my coach
or i didn't want to let my coach down
and you know i i'm doing it for him
because of the way he's taught me or
treated me or whatever it may be you're
going to lose that in oklahoma state
this year i mean that's beyond i mean no
player they're going to be like if
things get tough and he's you know no
player's going to go well i'm going to
stay out here and and work a little bit
longer they're going to screw that coach
he doesn't he's not worried about us so
why would i worry about him you're not
going to get any of that effect of the
players laying it on the line for the
coach anymore it's going to be just
about all about them which it should be
them to a degree but a great coach
brings those things out of you and mike
ben mcgundy will go on silent ears from
here on out i would expect especially
with the african-american players on the
team and yeah i would think recruiting
is going to be a big time struggle now
for him as well
and chris this is the next step in this
evolution of
college athletes recognizing they have
rights this idea of we're just going to
give you a scholarship and then we can
do whatever we want and college football
coaches that you know that woody hayes
figure that authoritarian this is my
team i say what
look people are realizing that there is
hypocrisy throughout college football
and you've got the coach who's making
millions the player who a lot of you
look and let's be realistic about it a
lot of these guys just want to play
professional football but they can't
because the nfl and the nflpa are
complicit and a system that forces them
to play college football for three years
what else are they going to do they
can't go to the draft even if they are
ready to play in the nfl so they go to
college to major in football they're not
there i mean look a lot of them they get
lured in oh hey you've been a great
player all your life you've been a great
you've been a dominant high school
player we're recruiting you to come play
major college football they think
they're going to play in the nfl even
though a small percentage of them
actually will and they're starting to
realize you know what
we we have power here
and we aren't treated fairly and equally
when you consider how much money we
bring in and i think what shuba hubbard
did the other day was a manifestation of
the idea that screw this
we aren't getting a fair piece of the
pie the coach as a result is getting a
bigger piece of the pie than he should
we're not going to cower to this guy
anymore when he does something that we
disagree with that shows sensitivity to
things we deal with every day we're
going to say something about it we're
going to do something about it good for
chuba hubbard good for the oklahoma
state players and it's a bad look for
mike gundy what what well look
am i surprised after the dumb stuff he
said in april about the pandemic no i'm
not surprised it's just uh maybe it's
overdue that we're kind of figuring out
who this guy really is and maybe it's
overdue for him to no longer be the head
coach at oklahoma state chris
well yeah i mean i think he's he's done
you know
done the duty for us there to kick off
you know that topic of conversation and
we'll see where it goes but there's
going to be a microscope under him now
or over him certainly dissecting every
little thing he does so he'll have to be
extra careful and mike i just want to
echo what you said about chuba chuba
hubbard i mean uh hopefully this is a
guy that's broke broke the ice here with
this a little bit and yeah maybe he can
give a voice to the rest of college
football the college football players it
has to be guys like him like you said
and we talked about this a little
yesterday it can't be like the 77th
scholarship on the college football team
guy that does that you know it's sorry
this is gonna be something that's gonna
you know the good players are going to
have to bear the burden of this but it's
going to have to be those type of
players chuba hubbard one of the best
running backs in college football so he
knows i'm starting running back this
year no matter what you know and and
he has the power to do that and he'll be
able to get away with things that other
players on that team would never have
been able to get away with so i think
maybe this will embolden some more star
college players to
hold their their colleges and their
teams more accountable and their head
coaches as we go forward
and it's not like oklahoma state is a
juggernaut eight and five last year
seven and six the year before gundy's
been the head coach since 2005.
one top 10 finish in his career there it
was back in 2011 when they finished
third in the ap poll and they won in the
fiesta bowl look hey it
it's it's a lot easier to look the other
way if you're oklahoma's coach not
oklahoma state's coach because oklahoma
is in the mix every single year it's
harder and look they should
i my point is this what's right is right
but it's harder for oklahoma state to
make excuses for mike gundy if the team
isn't a powerhouse so i i think the
margin for error for him is a lot
smaller now than it would have been and
yeah it could be that that he starts
getting a lot more scrutiny for these
so-so seasons than he would have gotten
whatever equity he had from 2011 is gone
now especially after what we've seen
this year from the way he handled the
pandemic to the stuff this week and uh
uh and and look
folks if if you want to believe that
this is cancel culture if you want to
believe the stuff the dog whistlers are
gonna are gonna sell you that's your
business the reality here though is this
is more than just the t-shirt the guy
wore this is whether or not a man who
makes 5.1 million dollars per year off
of a football team that is primarily
composed of young black men
is sensitive to the issues in this
moment
at this time
ever after everything that's happened
the last 23 days if you're not showing
sensitivity to those issues now you have
no business coaching a room that is
consistent primarily of young black men
period
period uh well said i got nothing to add
to that you're exactly right and um i i
think i've exhausted myself with this
conversation
all right uh that's it for today's pft
ot we'll be back tomorrow for thursday
or as chris would say friday either way
stick with us all day long at
profootballtalk.com and we'll see you
back here tomorrow
peace out